just nine weeks after taking over as
Twitter chief executive Elon Musk is
pulling the plug during his brief tenure
he pushed through a series of
controversial changes ruffling feathers
and prompting calls for him to quit so
he put it to a pole more than 17 million
people voted and the majority 57.5
percent to be exact told him to go
Tesla shareholders frustrated at the
boss's Antics over at Twitter may have
been among them
the company's share price has fallen
more than 60 percent this year and Elon
musk's Antics on Twitter have had no
small part to play in that he's very
Mercurial he says one thing he does
another there's no real predictability
and the main thing to be assured of is
that he'll do exactly what he wants to
do so what else is there left for him to
do other than basically turn Twitter
back into a money-making business which
it's not really at the moment and it
wasn't before and it certainly isn't in
this current shape so really he needs a
commercial CEO to take it over
be careful what you wish for the saying
goes in Elon musk's case he may have
just got it the latest stunt could be
just what he needed to wean himself off
the social media company and shift his
Focus back on Tesla where shareholders
have been growing increasingly irate at
his behavior
what next for the social media giant a
company in turmoil now possibly in
search of a successor to Elon Musk
but has the job become a poison chalice
gurpreet nawan Sky News